サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
早速テーマに入ります
できるだけ時間を残したいと思っています
皆様の質問もあるでしょうし
最後に書いてないいろんな情報がありましてね
それも時間があったら説明したいと思います
必先の幸福 必先ですね
はい それで今日のポイントは因果法則
幸福と因果法則の関係なんですね
因果法則の説明できませんからね
ちょっと難しいのでね
はい まず幸福の意味 人には希望がある
その希望が叶うと幸福といいます
いたって単純でしょ で
この仏教は単純でいたっても
これは事実真理ですから
そのまま理解してください
この幸福ってややこしいこと考える必要はないんです
一人一人に希望があって
その希望が叶ったら ああ
幸せだという風でいてしまうんです
それは未来に対する期待ですね
希望っていうのは未来に対する期待ですよ
今あるものに希望しないでしょ
ちょっと痩せたいなと思ったら
今は痩せないでしょうね
だから未来で痩せたら
あーよかったと で そこで幸せ感じるんです
今の瞬間 何かの不満 不安
不満がなければ成り立ちません
これで矛盾が出てくるんです
幸せを感じたければ 今あなたは不満でなければダメなんです
今満足であるならば 幸福を感じるということは
今満足しているならば幸福を感じますけど
あんまり人々は今の現状で幸福を感じないっていうのは人間の病気なんですね
だから矛盾があって 幸福を目指す連中はみんな不幸な連中なんです
暗くて 幸福になりたいなと思ったら暗いんですよ
でも私は幸せだというね
人間よくないんですね
幸福の計画を立てる必要がなければ
その場合はわざわざ今幸福であるならば
幸福になる計画を考える必要はないんです
しかし その時 今までの人生を振り返っています
振り返っています そこで今幸福だと言っている人々は数少ないんだけど
今までの人生を振り返っているんです
いわゆる過去を考えているんですね
過去でいろいろあって
こういうこともあって
今何一つなく 全部 OK やと
だから今幸福を感じるためには過去に不幸でないと
なかへんですね 過去は苦労があったはずですね
すごい 今幸福感による人にとっては
過去は何か苦労があったはずなんです
どう見たって矛盾ですね
そこでちょっと難しくします
相対的な幸福 これは英語で relative happiness なんですね
ということは本物じゃないということなんですね
幸福を期待するために不安
不安 不満が必要ですね
でなければ わかりやすくお腹が空いていないと
ご飯を食べておいしいななんて幸せだなと思えないでしょう
小さな苦を乗り越えて小さな幸福と
大きな苦を乗り越えて大きな幸福を感じるんですね
これ相対的なんですね
立っていて ちょっと疲れてくる
不幸ですね 小さな苦しみ
それで腰をかけるところがあって
そこで腰をかけて ああ
よかった ほんのわずかな幸せですね
すごい問題があって それを解決したらものすごい幸せな感じ
例えば自分の子供が何かで麻薬とか何とかで捕まって裁判にかけられて
ものすごい苦労して苦労していて
お金もなくなって 結局は裁判で無罪だって決めちゃうと
あの瞬間ですと もうよかった
神様ありがとう 仏様ありがとうと言うでしょ
で それはたくさん大きい苦があったからなんです
反対のということで 幸福ってなんかくだらんね
苦しみが作ってくるんです
ということで 反対の現象に支えられているので
人が人でしたっけ？人が考える幸福は常に不安定です
だから幸福にサポートしているのは不幸だからね
全く正反対でしょ？じわじわとチャラになっちゃうんですよ
かなり危険状態なんです
これを皆様は日常生活の中でよくチェックしてください
幸福を感じると 裏にそれに反対するこの幸福を支えてくれた相対的に苦があるんです
苦と幸福が一緒になっているんだから
潰れちゃうんです 木造の家を作ってシロアリも買ってあげたらどうですかね
ですから この維持するための努力が必要なんですね
幸福になったからといって落ち着けないのです
ずっとその幸福を維持しなくちゃいけないんです
維持しないと反対 相対的なあれ
苦しみが壊してしまうんです
さらに壊れてしまう可能性もあります
なんか意味がないね その文章は
で 幸福になっても その幸福がずっとあるわけじゃなくて壊れるんです
子供が生まれて幸せだなと思った人がね
子供が大人になっていろいろやっていると
あの幸せを感じなくなっちゃうんです
ただ 苦しみだけになる場合もあります
はい だいたいそれで仏教的なこの幸福っていうのは相対的である
それも相対っていうのは因果法則なんです
因果法則のはちょっと別な取り方なんですね
いわゆる現状 の説明で
現象現状が大したことはない
なんかインチキだと で
なんか反対のものに支えられているんだと
はい 次のポイントでいきましょう
幸福の勘違い それで我々一般人が考える幸福の説明終わったんだけど
その幸福には勘違いあるんです
一番の大きな勘違いは
幸福は恵みだと思っていることですね
恵みって単語がいいかどうか分かりませんだけど
これ英語でプロビデンスという単語なんで
キリスト教の単語ですけどね
神の恵み これものすごい勘違いなんです
これ なんでそういう勘違いがあるのかというと
自分と他人を比較して見るとき
お風呂会です 自分が他人と比較するんですね
余計なことを もういろいろ問題あるにも関わらず
また森の中での毒蛇を捕まってはポケットに入れる
何のためにやるかはよくわからない
人は同一ではないと同時に
恵みも同一なものになります
人は平等ですよ 生命は平等と同一という
私は言葉を 2つ使っているんです
平等っていうのはイコールなんですね
同一っていうのはアイデンティカルなんです
それはないんです 例えば
お母さんにとっては 3人の子供はみんな平等です
平等に心配する 平等に可愛がってあげる
平等に面倒見てあげる
平等にご飯を作ってあげたりする
しかし 子供 3人はアイデンティカルじゃないんです
それぞれ違うんです ですから
皆さんもよく気をつけてね
平等と同一っていうのは 2つであると理解してください
同一なものはないんです
例えば このペットボトルはなんだらかんだらの会社のペットボトルですけど
みんなに酒を売って人を殺してる会社作った
あの えーと 何でしたっけ？ミネラルウォーターですけど
じゃあ同じ会社のもう 1本ミネラルウォーターを持ってきたら
同一 どう見ても同じに見えるんだけど
水が違うんですね 結局は
ボトルも別々なんです
ですから 同じだから平等なんですけど
同一じゃない ペットボトルにしたっても
同一なものはないんです
よくそれ理解しない みんな
平等と同一をごちゃまぜにする
それで人々は余計なことをするんですね
見て あの人は私よりとても美しくて
私は恵まれていない あの人はすごい健康で体力があって
それにしたら私は恵まれていないとか
そういう悲観的なものもあるし
逆に逆もありますよ あれはね
あの人々みんな病気でね
いろいろ病を抱えて 私は元気
ピンピンですよとかね
そういう風にも考える
私は恵まれている あの人はもう学費払うどころか
子供たちにご飯を作ってあげることも大変苦しんでますよとかね
それに比べたら私はまあ週 3回焼肉食べてますよと
子供たちと一緒に 月2回
どこかのいいレストランに行ってご飯食べてますよ
私は恵まれているという風に思う人々もいるんです
ね 神の計らいなどの邪見が
だからそういう風に この恵み
恵まれているという これが邪見なんです
で しっかり宙広がってますよ
人間っていうのは面白いんですよ
アイディアが間違っているならば
ものすごい強烈に信じるんです
正しいことを言っちゃうと
ん？ということになっちゃうんです
無視するんです だから宗教ある人
無宗教家って みんな結局は神のことを信じてるんです
だって嘘だから それでいい加減な観察する
国同士で考えれば アメリカはとても豊かな国でとかね
アフリカの国々はすごく貧しくてとかね
で いい加減に観察するんです
正しく観察しない だってアメリカはなんでそんなに豊かですか？強豪でしょ？強豪で活動する
それは盗みでしょ？強盗でしょ
今ドルもね もうアメリカは全部もういろんな決まり決まりで
もう自分だけだけ幸せであればいいかと
このグローバルエコノミーという概念を先に出したのはアメリカで
それで世界を搾取できるだろうと思ったんです
アイデアが出たところでみんな頑張っちゃったんだから
中国が勝ってしまっちゃったんです
それでこれ否定 却下 俺だけ幸せになればいいって
だから強豪で強盗なんです
それでアフリカっていうのはアメリカより財産がある資源があるんですね
全部強盗されてるんですね
いろんな外国の会社たちから
で 政治家に賄賂を払っちゃえば
政治家はなんとかもう強引に国民を抑えてあげてるんです
だから銀行強盗すれば大金が手に入りますよ
別に それでその人は恵まれていると言う
だからこのいい加減で研究するんだから
で 恵まれている 恵まれていないという概念が現れるんですね
そこでこの大体人間の大勢の人々は
自分が世界と比較するとついてないと思うんです
世界的にはまあもう指で数えられるぐらい何人かの人間だけでしょ
ビル・ゲイツさんレベルの
何人かですよ まあ問題ない
最高だと思っているのはね
でも個人的に調べたら色々問題抱えてるはずなんです
だから私たちは世界と比較してみると
過ぎてないね 当然ですね
だからこの神というこの妄想概念使っちゃうと
皆ものすごいネガティブに陥っちゃうんです
そこで宗教は嘘言って神は大慈悲であって
すべての生命は平等に愛しているとか
完璧嘘でしょ はい その問題を聞いたのは
この業ということ ブッダ以外誰も語っていないんです
業みたいな話はヒンドゥー教でジャイナ教でもありますけど
あれはもうあまりにも原始思考で
ちゃんと真理発見して語られているものじゃないんです
運命論みたいなもんなんですね
それは矛盾だらけで成り立たない
しかし ジャイナ教の教論も全く矛盾だらけで成り立たない
読んでみたらすごく理屈っぽく感じるんです
でも ちょっと深く行ってみると矛盾だらけ
お釈迦様はジャイナ教の業の場合は矛盾しっかりと見せてあげたんです
なんでバラモン人の業論に対応してないのかと
あの連中は業論を持っていなかったんです
なんとなく考えあっただけでなかったんです
そこでの業っていう働きがあります
それは理解していない
業は心を起動させるエネルギーですが
普通の人間に発見できないんです
心を起動するエネルギーでしょ
だから自分の心はどのように働いているのかというと
自分が結果得られるんです
子供 3人が勉強すると
3人は 3種類の衝動を持っているんです
同じ本を開けて同じ時間勉強しても
心の働くエネルギーがそれぞれ違うんです
だから結果が違うんです
例えば あまり活発でない
あまりやりたくない エネルギーがない
その子はやっぱり点数が下がるんです
それで私は恵まれていないとか
アホなことを言う 私のこと
私のことを神が恨んでいるとか
くだらんことを言う ただ
お前の心にエネルギーがない
それだけなんです 業のエネルギーが弱いんだったら
何やっても弱い結果になるんです
業のエネルギーがすごい強いんだったら
もう何でも簡単にもううまくいきます
問題は それをその個人にはっきり理解することはできないんです
で 我々ヴィパッサナー瞑想
自己観察などなど教えるんだけど
それで心の流れが発見できますけど
業がどんな風に割り当てて介入するのか
それはなかなか難しいんです
それはお釈迦様だけの超智慧で発見して説かれたものですね
だから 業については 我々はこのブッダの話を素直に学ぶしかないんですね
他人と自分の生き方 生き方なんかを比較して
ついてる人とついてない人という区別差別をします
結果として人類が不幸
なんかちょっとおかしい
文章がガチャガチャハチャメチャになっている
不幸を乞う人間になったのです
だから業がわからないんだから
幸福をこう  ん？何  幸福を乞う人間
今 不幸を  あ そうですか
幸福を乞う人間になっているんですね
くじけですね 人間が結局は
まあこう 自棄っていうか
単語は良くないんだけど
だからアメリカなんかはね
で ホームレスなんかはね
恵みをちょうだいって言うんですね
人々に それでみんな一応いくらかお金出したりするんだけど
私に言われたら神に言ってください
恵みは神がくれるものだと
私だったらお金ちょっとちょうだいと言ってくださいと
その場合はお金が私が持っていて
その人は持ってないですから
あげられます 恵みはあげられません
はい この業がわからないんだから
人間が好いてる人間好いてない人間と私たち勝手に区別して
それから差別する 他人に自分を幸福にすることは不可能です
それは業です 人の心にエネルギーをあげる入れることはできないんです
仏教的に考えても この人の業を修復すればいいでしょ
そういう業にしなくちゃあかんでしょ
それはできない 祈りは祈りは気が弱い人の逃げ場です
祈りに何のあり得もないではなくて
祈ったらなんとなく落ち着くだけ
まあ責任逃れもできますしね
頑張らないで どうか神様助けてくださいと
どうか子供の病気が治りますようにとかね
祈ったらなんとなく微妙に落ち着くんだけど
自分が祈ったからといって子供の病気だったら治療を受けなくちゃいけないし
子供に病気を治す精神力がなければどうにもならない
それも業ですよ いわゆる生き続けるすごい業
業があると たまたま病気になってもすぐそこは何とかして治しちゃうんです
生き続けられるエネルギーがなくなると
どうにもならない いくら治療を施しても死ぬんです
はい 因果法則に入ってみましょう
世は因果関係で成り立っています
何でも因果関係で成り立っています
原因によって成り立たない現象は一切ありません
はい この書いてある文章というのは
聖書の文章よりぴったしですから
このまま暗記したっても構いません
何の間違いもないんです
文章を書く場合は 神様より私の方が腕がいいんです
で 矛盾がないように書けます
矛盾があったら それは私は意図的に矛盾を入れる場合あります
そうでないとないんです
はい それで一切現象 皆様方は神様を信仰してもいいでしょう
それも現象です 鬼を信仰してもいいのです
しかし 現象です 実際 目の前に鬼がいるとしても構いませんよ
鬼に握手できるとかね
鬼の写真撮れるとかね
それぐらい証拠はあっても構いません
私には でも現象は現象です
私も現象です 皆様は現象です
この建物も現象です すべてこの現象というものは
因縁 因縁によって成り立っているのです
何か理由があるのです
そこで私たちはこの因果法則を誤解することがあって
原因があって現れちゃったと
因と結果が分かれてみるんですね
これちょっと難しい すーっと因が働いて
すーっと果を出し続けなくちゃいけないんです
そこで因が消えた瞬間で結果も消えちゃうんです
そこでこちらで私がいるんだそうと言っても
ものすごい勢いで私の体の因果が因縁が働いて支えて
いるんです えーと あの空気のジェット作って
ジェットっていうのはあの空気がスーッと流れるものを作って
上に風船を乗せる そうすると風船が乗ったままでいることができます
しかし 上に風船が乗ってもらうために
水の空気のジェットがスーッと働かなくちゃいけないんです
しかし ちょっとずれちゃうとポシッと落ちるんです
かなり危うい状態なんです
この因果関係というのは
ほんのちょっと僅かにちょっとズレると
例えば時々ね 子供たちでもこのあれ
噴水の場合はね 夏とかは上に風船を乗せてみることはやる場合あるんですね
風船でも何か軽いものとかね
ほんのわずか上にいて
ちょっと落ちるんですね
だから 上にいる姿があの水の流れが決める
だから水がいいんで あのものが上にあるっていうことは結果で
だからそれぐらい 不安なんです
不安というんですかね
安定しないんです 因果法則は
ありえないんです 今も私の体が壊れて壊れていってるんです
喋るとエネルギーがなくなってなくなって
壊れて講演終わると疲れるっていうね
休まなくちゃいけないっていうことになるんですね
だから今も因果法則が働いているんです
因果法則が働かない瞬間がないんです
何を見ても このカメラを見ても
マイクロを見ても スクリーンを見ても
すべて因果法則で成り立っているんだから
あの風船の例えを覚えておいてください
このホールにはホールは明るいと言ったら
これ現象でしょ でもいきなり神様が明るくしてくれた？ない
因果法則です 照明があるんです
照明器具が そこは光っているから
しかし そちらにはスーッと電気が流れないと
だから瞬間で暗くすることはできます
では反対議論しましょう
では 薪で明るくしたらどうですか？と
同じことじゃん 薪が燃えている間は明るくて
その原因消えたら終わり
だから この邪見をなくしたければ
このフレーズを原因によって成り立たない現象は一切ありませんと覚えなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると宗教的な信仰でしょ？じゃない
調べてください 何でも調べてください
たとえ幻覚 幻想であっても
原因で起こるんです 例えば人に幻覚がある
幻想がある それも因果法則です
例えばマジシャンがいろんな原因
その場合は幻想ですかね
いろんな幻想を見せちゃうんですね
人の目を騙すんです 因果法則ない？あります
例えば ある人は精神的な病気で
自分にはいつでも神々が来ていろんなことを喋っているんだと
言われる お前変 病気 頭イカれてる
で いろんなこと言うでしょ
神が来て喋るわけないでしょ
そんなこと言う必要ないんです
原因があって その幻聴が幻覚が起きているんです
知恵のない人は 因縁を調べてもほとんど間違った結論に達するんです
それで因縁論の場合は
一般人に考えても何か間違った結論に達しちゃうんですね
ある程度では調べることはできますよ
例えば科学って何ですか？科学は現象の因果関係を探しているんです
そこで見つけて見つけて
科学的な知識とか 何とか何だらかんだら言うんです
それで因果法則なんです
例えば医学の世界で薬を開発する
因果法則でしょ こういう病気はこういうこういう原因で起こる
その原因をなくすために
こういうこういう物質を入れ替えればよろしいと
それから捉えるもやって
で 許可してもらう そちらも因果法則でしょ
でもしっかりした因果法則ではないんだから
そんなにぴったしの結果も出てこない
だから科学者が作っている科学というのはものすごくあるんだけど
まあ完璧な結果を出すということは
欲望通りに結果を出すということはないんですね
だから科学世界はある程度で因果法則を探しています
しかし 科学者は物質の因果法則を探しているんです
なぜ物質はどういう成り立ちなのかと
生きる 生きるって何なのかっていうことは全く研究していない
それは二次的な結果だと勘違いしているんです
仏教は生きるということの因果法則を探したんです
仏教にとっては 生きることは二次的なものじゃないんです
生きることがあって 他のことに興味があるだけ
生きていなきゃ何も関係なくなっちゃうんです
だから生きているから
宇宙はどうなっているのかとかね
宇宙はどうやって始めたのかとか
地球で人間はどうやって現れたのかとか
こういうくだらんことを探しているんです
物質のこと 結局は自分が生きるからでしょ
これをやっているのは
はい 一般人にはこれ 因果法則を完全に知ることはできないんだから
私たちは業だけではなくて
因果法則の場合でもブッダに聞く必要があるんです
幸福になりたいと思うならば
仏法を学んで理解し 実行することです
幸福に達することは確実です
だって因果法則を完全に知り尽くしているんだから
お釈迦様 あんたこうしなさいって言ったら
そうやってください 必ず結果が出ます
お釈迦様 私を信じてくださいと言ってないんです
試せ 試してみてどうですか？とすごい自信を持って言うんです
知らないことを知っている人から学ぶのは普通です
これは皆様に強引に言うことでも
押し付けることでも何でもないんです
ブッダの言葉を信仰しなということでもないんです
ただ わからないものはわかっている人から学ぶでしょう
今もやっているでしょう
人間として それって普通なことでしょう
私たち仏教側が言うのは
あなた方は知らないことが
仏教は知っていることはある
これを学んでみてください
それだけ ブッダの教えを学ぶことは
ブッダを盲信することではありません
はい そこで問題をいくつか出してみます
生命は貪瞋痴の感情で生きています
幸福概念は貪瞋痴が作ったものです
幸福になりたいでしょ
あれは貪瞋痴の結論なんです
貪瞋痴は悪 因です 因果法則で見ると
悪因は必ず悪果になります
これで何言いたいか分かりますか？裏で皆様方は幸福になりたいでしょ？それを自分のボケ都合で言うんです
何のこともないんです
自分自身自分のボケ都合っていうんです
それ言っちゃうとまずいんだから言えないんです
読めるようにしたんです
なぜならば 例えばね 痩せたいなと思ったら欲でしょ？体に肉体に対する執着でしょ
いろんな希望はあるでしょ
すべて貪瞋痴なんです
子供が最優秀で合格してほしいと
学校はとかね 母親が それ is 気持ちじゃないんですよ
母親の欲望なんです だからそう期待すると結果いつでも逆でしょ
これはみんな理解していないんです
こんなに勉強しろ 勉強してと
いつでも満点取れ 満点取れとか言っちゃうと逆になって
登校拒否って結果になっちゃうんです
それでなんだこれ 神様なんで？ではなくて
当然だよって言いたい
私は あなたは子供を壊しちゃったんだと
あなたの欲望で でもこれは一般世界では全然理解してくれないんです
これも当たり前 だって貪瞋痴だから
みんなこれ知らない世界があるんですよ
発見してない世界があるんです
金が欲しい欲しいと思っちゃうと貧乏になっちゃうんです
え？と思っちゃうでしょ
でもそれが因果法則です
だからお釈迦様が施しという与えることをしなさいと
欲しいっていうことを消してくださいと
あの欲望で与える行為をする
自分からいろんなものを社会に人類に与える
与えていくと この人は期待はしていないのに
はちゃめちゃ幸福になっているんです
それ因果法則です 善因だから欲をなくすこと
善因でしょ？善果になるんです
一般経済的ないい加減な知識ある人に
人に金をあげた方がいいよと
あんたもう儲かりますって
え？金をあげたらなくなるだけでしょうにと
くだらんことを言うなよと
金を儲けて儲けて貯金するべきだ
それでで 豊かになりますよと
俗世間の理屈なんです
でもそれ言っても違います
俗世間は悟ってないんです
宇宙法則 生命法則を知らないんです
だから 素直にブッダがおっしゃっているようにやってみたらどうですかと
幸福になるための努力は不幸という結果になる恐れが大きいんです
これは必ずしもと言えません
なぜならば 自分の心で業を持ってるんだから
貪瞋痴で生きたからといって
ドカンと不幸になることはないんです
だから 心にすごい業がある人はしっかり元気で活動している
その活動の結果が得られます
例えばすごく欲で もう金儲かりたくてしょうがない
もう億万長者になりたくて
しかし その人は精神的にすごいエネルギーなんです
ものすごい活動家なんです
じっとしていられない
何かやる 何かをやる そうすると当然
金持ちになって億万長者になっちゃうんです
で それで悪意を作ったでしょ
それは業に入っているんだから
そのうち結果が出ます
はい 問題2 結果ばかり気にするなら方法は愚かになります
そこで人間の間違い 問題1は幸福になりたいところ
将来の結果イメージ に引っかかっちゃうんです
それって自分の主観なんです
頭で作った妄想概念に引っかかっちゃって
そこを目掛けて進むんですね
登山家は頂上のことばかり考えると
山は登れません 頂上はいいな
なんて素晴らしいですかとかね
こんなくだらんことをいくら考えたっていい
一歩一歩登りなさいなんて
頂上にたどる道を調べて実行するべきでしょ
それが因果法則です だから自分に欲望で妄想的な幸福観があっても構いません
その自分のイメージする幸福にどうやってたどるのかと
この道を調べる必要があるんです
だから 結果を一時的に忘れてほしいんです
一時的でもなくてもいいんです
結果忘れて道を歩んでくださいと仏教は因果法則にのっとって言うんです
結果は忘れてしまっても頂上にたどるんです
登山家が道を調べて ここの場合はこうします
この場合はこうします
で 登山道も危険な道だからね
で この場合はロープを使います
この場合はつえを使いますとかね
あれやこれやとか その現場で対応するだけ
頂上まであって あと何日ですかと考えちゃうと落ち込んじゃうんですよ
今もくたくた苦しいんだけど
それでできなくなっちゃうんです
そうではなくて 目の前の問題を解決する
目の前の問題を解決すると
すると あらっと見たら登るところなくなっているんですね
登るところなくなったら頂上なんです
原因をそろうようにするならば
結果は自然に現れます
この必然的というのはそういうことなんです
原因そろうだけで 例えば照明器具があって
電線がちゃんとつなげて電気を入れてスイッチをオンにしたら光っちゃうんですよ
神様が光ってと言う必要ないでしょ
私は照明器具が光ることを期待する
アホでしょ？知らない
そんなのは 原因そろったら結果です
で マッチで火を起こす場合は
まずお祈りしてください
マッチ棒でこれから神様は火を起こしてください
現してください 恵みを与えてくださいと
それを祈っても火が現れますね
私は神様バカ野郎 てめえ殺してやると思ってやっちゃっても
火が現れる だから原因そろったら結果です
毎日それでしょう 朝ご飯に卵を焼く
原因そろってあげてください
フライパンに入れたり
ちょっと油入れたり 卵を割って入れたり
ガスの火をつけたりとかね
それでもののめぐりに卵焼きが現れているんです
だから ちょうどいいところで
これは自分が火を消さなくちゃいけない
火をつけたままだったら
卵焼き焼きになっちゃうんですね
焼かれた卵焼きになる
それも当然な結果なんです
天ぷらを揚げていて 電話がかけてきたところで電話に夢中になっちゃう
それで油がね 温度が上がって上がって火事になる
これで不幸ではない 当然な結果です
そちらに悪魔が割り込んだわけでもないんですね
自分の何と言いますか
先祖の霊が割り込んだわけでもないんです
どこまでいっても馬鹿かと
因果法則を知っていると
なんのことなく自由です
何の問題もないんです
何の足かせもないんです
頭がビシビシ働くんです
そういうことで 原因が揃うなら
揃うようにするならば
結果は自然に現れます
ですから 結論 すべての現象は当然で当たり前なんです
だって 障害を持って生まれる人がいるでしょ
みんな悩んだり困ったり
落ち込んだり あれやこれやと
仏教の真理を知っているんだったら
何のこともないんです
それは罰が当たったわけでも何でもないんです
因果法則の当然な結果なんです
だから別に悩んだり舞い上がったり
落ち込んだりではなく
普通に対応して 例えば仏教を知っているお母さんに障害を持って子供が生まれたら
全く自然に思うんですね
私はもう知ってますからね
大変です もう我々とよく喋りますからね
もう仏教の人々はね 自分の国だったらね
で 日本だけですね 私のことを怯えているのは
結構喋りますよ 怒られてもそれでも喋る
で ごく普通に言うんですね
あの 3 代目の子はね いろいろこういうことで
だからあれやこれやとかね
ごく自然にやるんですよ
協力が必要だったら まあちょっと協力が必要ですから
何とかしてくれませんか？とかね
不思議も奇跡も恵みも偶然もありません
これは頭イカれてる人々の概念です
世は因果法則です 世はすべての現象は当然な結果なんです
奇跡ありません 不思議なことありません
仏教も不思議という言葉は時々使いますよ
それはあなた方には理解できないという意味だけなんです
はい 問題さん 納得いかないという問題
人の思考は貪瞋痴の結果です
不幸は不貪不瞋不痴 これは善人の結果です
先生 幸福じゃない 幸福じゃない
幸福です  幸福は 幸福は不貪不瞋不痴の結果です
だから善人が必要なんです
善人について語っても
理解能力がないので納得しないんです
だって貪瞋痴で理解しなくちゃあかんでしょ
これを自分殺す気に殺される気になっちゃうんです
皆様にも最初に仏教を聞いたところで
何か侮辱された 非難されたと感じたでしょ
あれはあまりにも貪瞋痴があったからなんです
私の態度はあまりにも凶暴で日本向きじゃないとか
いろいろ私はニコッと笑って自分を直そうとしないんです
必要ないんです じゃあ待ってみろという態度でやるんです
どちらが正しいかと そこで私たちは貪瞋痴で考えているんです
貪瞋痴で考えている場合は
不貪不瞋不痴の思考を教えても
え？なんだこれ 変となっちゃう
魚に歩くことを教えるような感じなんです
蛇に足に据えて説法するような感じなんです
蛇の頭ではそういう思考はないんです
ですから この幸福の道を教えても
問題は人は納得しないんです
だから仏教はあえてちょっと強烈に
ちょっと何といいますか
凶暴に喋らなくちゃいけなくなっているんです
自分の気持ちに合う教えを探すんです
人々は自分の気持ちに合う
自分に納得できる教えを探しているでしょ
それすごい危険です 残念ながら
それは不幸に達する道なんです
あの人の話は気に入ったと
あなたの貪瞋痴にぴったし合致しましたなんです
だから仏教を学べたけど
真理を学べたければ覚悟する必要ありますよ
嫌なことを聞く羽目になるんだと
自分を貶されることを聞く羽目になるんだと
その覚悟が必要なんです
私の気持ちに合わせて私の機嫌を取って喋ると言ったら
あれは嘘を喋らなくちゃいけないんです
だから貪瞋痴に誘惑することはいたって簡単ですよ
この神様を信仰すれば
永遠の天国に生まれますよとかね
何なんだと唱えれば もう極楽道で金の蓮の花の上に生まれるんだと硬い手はと言っているんですけど
みんなもう行きたいんですね
極楽道は全部蓮の花ばっかしで
それの金でできていて
その上に人間がポツンと現れるところです
気持ち悪いと思うんだけど
誰も気持ち悪いと思わないね
そこで大音で悟る それは貪瞋痴に訴えているんだからね
屁理屈でしょ 金の上にいるっていうことは
金っていうのは硬いでしょ
ふわふわしたところに座りたくない
はい 問題  4 失敗するという問題
宣言が揃うように努力しても失敗する
中断する 諦めるなどが起きます
これ 誰にもあります 他宗教全く知らない
仏教しか知らない 生まれつき仏教徒であっても
幸福の道をたどると中断したり
諦めたり 失敗したり ハチャメチャですよ
それは心の 基礎である貪瞋痴が攻撃するからですね
だから頑張ったからといって
基礎が心の基礎が貪瞋痴だから
そちらも黙っていないんですね
自分の善行に邪魔をするんです
幸福を目指す人は 己の心の中に不幸になるプログラムも実行していることを発見しなくてはならない
そこで正しい答えは善行してください
不貪不瞋不痴を実践してください
しかし だからといってうまく進むはずがない
なぜならば 自分の心の中で不幸のプログラムも起動しているんです
だから とにかくやがてそれを抑えて停止させなくちゃいけないんです
はい はい これで今日の話で一番私は言いたいところに入ります
大事なポイントに幸福概念の何でだ
これは掃除 掃除してほしい
健康 財産 権力 知識 家族
長寿云々は俗人が考える幸福です
本当につまらない あんた幸福になりたいか
なりなりたい どうなったら幸福になる？もうちょっとお金があれば
そんなもんです あるいはあんた幸福になりたい
なりたいんです どうすればあんた幸福になる？子供はもっと真面目に勉強してくれれば
そんなもんでしょ そんなつまらないことを考えているんです
これは社会が決めた価値観でしょ
あなたの幸福じゃないでしょ
社会に騙されているんです
これが一つも自分のものにならないんです
お金であろうか 知識であろうか
健康であろうが 幸せな家庭であろうが
一つも自分のものにならないんです
自分とは関係ない 勝手に変化するんです
幸せな家庭を築いたと一人が勝手に思っても
家族のメンバーたちがみんな勝手に行動しているんです
いい会社にいい仕事に就きましたと言っても
それあなたの仕事ではないでしょう
自分の管轄外なんです
管理不可能です だからそんなものは自分のものになりました
いい仕事に就きました
給料もなかなかいいだよとか
将来性もあるんだよと勝手に喜んでも
結果どうでしょうか と聞きたくはなるんです
この体さえ自分勝手に働くんです
じゃあ体だけ私のもの？違うんです
勝手に体が働くんです
さらに言います あなたの心はあなたのもの
心って心の勝手でしょ
言う通りにならないでしょ
勝手に妄想する 勝手に落ち込む
どうにもならない 管理できない
心さえ自分のものでないんだから
あなた方は何言ってるんですかね？世界制覇したいとか
こんなバカなことあるんですかね
世界制覇した人がいる
そうやっちゃうと作った銅像まで壊されますからね
レーニンやら何でしたっけ？イラクのあの人フセインとかね
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみでそれを壊されるんです
結局は本人が世界制覇したつもりですね
だからでっかい銅像を作っておいたんです
お考えと だから皆さんはこう思ってください
この心さえ言う通りにならない
肉体は言う通りにならない
そこを理解してください
ですから 言う通りにならないもの
管理不可能なものを手に入れようとすること自体変でしょ
それは手に入ったら私は幸せだと
あのね 手に入りません
ですから あなたは一向に幸せにならないという結果になります
ただ奴隷になるだけ 例えば金持ちたい
奴隷でもう奴隷ではっちゃめちゃ苦労して仕事をすれば
飲ませ食わせる 寝ない
寝ないで金が入るんでしょ？でもあんた奴隷でしょ？入った金はあなたのもの
国がそこを奪うんです
税金払えとか消費税払えとか
だから使う権利すらないんです
そこでなおさら欲があったら
金をいろんなところに入れちゃう
もっとこれ増えてほしいやと
全部パーになっちゃう
なくなっちゃう ですから
このそこら辺で思考を生じしてほしいんですね
自分のために現れる働くものはありません
これが私のために現れたということはないんです
時々親たちはもう私のために子は生まれて産んでくれ
生まれてきたとか バカなことを考える
いえ 自分のためじゃないんです
自分がただ生まれてきた赤ちゃんの奴隷になっただけです
一時的に付き合うことができても
捨てされなくてはいけないんです
一時的に まあ金とちょっと付き合う
一時的に知識と付き合う
まあ散歩に行ったら 途中で会った人にはこんにちは
お元気ですか？と喋る程度ですよ
人生は この我々考えている幸福は
それから捨てされなくちゃいけないんです
それが真理で事実です
それ否定すると決まって幸福
不幸になる はい そこで続きあります
裸で一文無しで生まれて
何も持たず行くんです
残るのは俗世間の現象を無理に自分のものにしようとして
いわゆる法則を犯して
作った愛着 憎しみ 落ち込み
不安 不満 失望感などなどを持って死ぬんです
赤ちゃんが不満でオギャーと泣いて生まれますけど
死ぬ時も同じですよ 膨大な悩み
苦しみ 不安を抱えて 心をもうはっちゃめちゃ汚しちゃって死ぬんです
だから結局幸福になるために頑張ったんだけど
結果はみんな不幸に陥って死ぬんです
じゃあ私の言葉に入れ替えます
みんな幸福だと思って
地獄の道を地獄行きの道を歩んでいるんです
はい 要するに 生きるとは必死で心を汚して悪因のみ蓄積することです
だから幸福という概念を掃除してください
これは危険です 我々は
俗世間が思っている幸福は悪因ばっかし作る道なんです
いわゆる罪を犯す道なんです
悪因は悪果になるんです
死後 今よりも不幸に陥る道です
はい 幸福を目指して地獄に行くか
本当に幸福に達するのかと心で判断しなくてはいけない
だから私たちには判断が必要です
愚か者たちが 世間が自分も幸福に達していないのに
これが幸福 これが幸福だと勝手に言うこと
例えばテレビで画面に出てくる人の顔を見て
なんて美しい人です なんて体格がいい人だと勝手に思っちゃって
本人に会ってみたら なんだこれは
私は結構がっかり がっかりはしてないんだけど
ある人は背がすごく低いんですよ
私よりも テレビ画面で見るとすごい体格いいんですね
上半身しか映らないせいだから
みんなそういうことなんです
だから我々はあの人なら幸せ
この人なら幸せとかね
自分勝手に妄想してそれを目指すという
あんまり屁理屈な道を歩んでいるんです
だから本当に幸福になるか
あるいは幸福だと思って地獄に落ちるかと
地獄に落ちる道が世間で誰だって言ってるんです
しっかり勉強しなさい
幸せになりますからと
本当にそう？よくいい仕事に就きなさい
幸せになります 本当にそう？そうじゃない
だから この悟ってない俗世間が
貪瞋痴で無知で動く俗世間が私たちを騙しているんです
カモにしているんです
我々はみんなカモにされているんです
すべての人間が 世間が言う価値観に言うんです
それではなくて ブッダが説いた心理学を理解して
心が貪瞋痴で働くんだと
貪瞋痴は不幸を作るんだと
だから不貪 不瞋 不痴を実行しなくちゃいけないんだと
そうすると善果になりますと
良い結果になるんだと理解しなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 心を清らかにすることを目指す
ですから 幸福になりたいだったら
まず心を清らかにしてください
心のゴミを捨ててください
それが正しい道なんです
人格向上すること 無常の現象に愛着を持たない精神を育てることは目指すんです
抜群に幸福になります
当然に幸福になります
当たり前の幸福になります
これは世間が言っているくだらんことじゃないんです
幸福という概念に足が引っ張られることをやめて
やめてください 頂上に登る
頂上を忘れてください
だから人間がこれが幸福だとほんのわずかな目的を設定する
仏教は目的設定しない
オープンにするんです
だから心を清らかにすればするほど
成功すればするほど じわじわ
じわじわより幸福になる
より幸福になる リミットがなくなっちゃうんで
幸福の 世間に騙されると
まずリミットを作る そこを目指すんです
これらのすべてが善根です
今言ったこと すべて善根を揃うことなんです
原因揃ったら結果が当然
祈らなくても大丈夫です
はい 幸福になるために我々は何をするべきかというと
心を汚さないこと 心のゴミをなくすこと
それだけ 幸福は勝手に勝手に来るんです
別に期待する 期待する必要すらないんです
うん うん 人は幸福から幸福へ進むので
このブッダが教えた通りに行くと
幸福から幸福へ進むんです
人は定める幸福感は得られるはず
すべての幸福にブレーキがかけます
人は幸福って設定すると
この人は無数の幸福にブレーキかけてるんです
だから無限に幸福になれますけど
子供がいい大学に入れば幸せと思っちゃうとブレーキかけてるんです
あんた仕事のこと心配
仕事のことはどうでもいいんです
うちの子はいい大学に入ってもらえばということで
すごい不幸な考えでしょ？すごい暗い思考でしょ
だから幸福にリミットつけないでください
それは皆様持ってる欲望で
喋ると理解できます 皆様方
金持ちたいでしょ？金額はどれぐらい儲かりたい？その場合
欲にリミットないんだから
金額にリミットがないでしょ
金ならいくらあっても大丈夫だということになるんです
だから 欲の世界でそういう大変なことになるんだからね
仏教は幸福のことを語って
リミットをつけないでくださいとあえて言うんです
金儲かりたかったらリミットをつけてくださいと言うんです
いくらあっても幸せと思わないでくださいと
あんたひどい目にあいますよと
だから 欲世間に対してリミットをつけてくださいと言うし
仏教の世界ではリミットを外してくださいと言うんです
だから仏教がリミットがない幸福の道
幸福の道を教えているんです
で 狙った幸福にも達するか否かすらわからないんですね
人間というのは幸福をリミット作る
幸福のイメージを作る
このイメージに達するか失敗するか
それもわからないでしょ？五分五分でしょ
心を清浄にすることに進む人を励む人は
直ちに安らぎ 安穏を感じます
心清浄しようと思ったら
その瞬間から安らぎを感じます
それから幸福 幸福 幸福
幸福 幸福 その人は宣言ばかり作っているからです
はい それで幸福の完了もあります
宣言を作る人は 千五百煩悩で汚れている心を丁寧に掃除するんです
心の汚れは千五百という風に
ちょっとかっこつけた数字があります
基本的には貪瞋痴だけですけどね
無常たる現象 要するに生ゴミ
に愛着を捨てて 捨てて捨てて進むんです
我々は消えるものに 壊れるものに愛着を持っているんです
例えば知識が欲しいと
知識も消えるんです 毎日のように訓練しないと
年取っていくと自分から離れていくんです
金も自分のものじゃないんですよ
自分の名義の中に銀行口座に入っても
これ自分のものじゃないんです
で なんで自分のものでないのに
そちらに執着愛着してハチャメチャ頑張るんですかね
だからこの心を清らかにするとは
この生ゴミに対する愛着を捨てていくんです
一切の現象に愛着がなくなったところで
心の清浄は終了です だからこう理解しやすい
愛着 愛着をなくしていくんです
愛着は あ これは無常だから不可能でしょう
例えばちっちゃい子供はすごく可愛いんですね
なんて可愛い子が生まれてきたのかと
ほんのわずかな時間で可愛くなくなるんです
体が変わるんだから だから
まあ可愛いなったら可愛いでいいって
まあ一時的でいいんですよ
別に 愛着は作る必要はないんです
相対的ではない絶対的な幸福に達します
いわゆる不幸が作った幸福ではなく
純絶対的幸福に達します
それは仏教用語で涅槃というんですね
いわゆるフィニッシュという意味なんです
何がフィニッシュ？苦しみがフィニッシュ
不幸がフィニッシュです
祈りの代わり 祈りは惨めです
小精神です しかし 汚れた心も弱いんですね
進む力がないんです 人間に
問題に対処する力がない
心が汚れているんだから
祈りの...だから祈っちゃうんです
祈ってちょっといい気分になる
仏教は祈りの代わりに誓願ということをしてくださいと言うんです
誓願してください これは心理学的な働きなんです
誓願すると自分に誓願するんです
心に そうすると弱い心にやる気が生まれるんです
だから弱い業で生まれても
誓願しっかり誓願すると
あの弱みがなんとかなんとか補うことはできます
だから仏道で推薦するのは祈りではなく
誓願すること 例えば 私はとにかく怒りをなくすように頑張ります
怒りをなくしてみますと決める
それが誓願だ 心を清浄することをすると
誓願したら心に進む力
これがないんだから みんなに貪瞋痴の心を持っていると
努力する力がない 進む力がない
時々何か障害にぶつけても乗り越える力がない
だから誓願が必要なんです
誓願が入れると進む力
負けない力 負けてもやりますという力が生まれてくるんです
だから仏教では祈りはなし
お釈迦様はある日でからかっちゃったんです
祈っちゃえば 祈ったことを得るならば
人は何祈ってもいいでしょうにと
何もしないで祈るだけで
でも祈ったからといって得るわけないでしょ
明確な証拠あるでしょ
否定する 祈りのおかげで子供が病気になったら祈りばっかりやってください
そういうキリスト教の信仰
宗教 組織があったんですよ
神は全知全能 神は完全なもの
神は不完全なものを作りません
ですから 子供が病気になったら治療しないで
みんな子供を囲って囲まって祈る
祈ったら結果として子供が死ぬ
死んだらありがたく埋葬する
神様がうちの子は早くも天国に呼んでもらうになったと
どれほどアホかと それでアメリカのなんですけど
番組で見たんだけど 警察の人々に聞いたら
なんであなた方は行って調べないんですかと
これできないんだと 宗教だから
宗教は自由でしょうと
しかし その同じ警察官がお墓見せたんです
で こういう子供たち たくさんペニシリン注射で治る病気だよと
要するに １０ドルもかからない
殺してるんです だから
この他の人々は祈りながら治療もする
だから治ったら神様ありがとうございますって言う
自分でハチャメチャ苦労して
ごちそう作って 天にまします
神様は私に今日食事を与えてくれて感謝いたしますと祈っちゃうでしょ
やってやってください
自分が頑張ったことは忘れちゃうんです
まあとにかく だから仏教は科学的に祈りやめて誓願してくださいと決めてください
心で それでエネルギーが生まれるんです
善行 功徳の意味 すぐ終わるとは思います
功徳を積んだら幸福になると
低次元に理解するところに欲が現れて
俗世間的な現象に執着が生まれるので
かえって心は汚れるんです
なんか分からないね 意味は
私もよく分かりません
これは仏教徒の人々の問題なんですよ
皆様の問題じゃないんです
私はその文化で育てられましたからね
だから善行をしなさい
善行をしなさいと赤ちゃんが出るから言われているんですよ
これ 今日のテーマみたいに深く心理に入らないんです
善行をしなさいと 欲が良くないよ
怒りが良くないよとかね
慈悲の瞑想したら徳が積めますよとかね
そんな程度で終わっちゃうんです
そこで一般人がどれぐらい徳を積んだのかと数えるんです
あの自分の国ではこの功徳メモ帳あるんです
売ってます 自分の名前を書いて
日にちを毎日書いて 今日はどれぐらい功徳を積んだのかとかね
みんな真剣に 特におばあさんたちは真剣に書くんです
だから功徳手帳っていうのは何冊もたくさんなっちゃうとありがたいですよね
空ければ功徳 功徳 功徳
功徳とかね 同時に悪行為のあれもメモ帳も作った方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
それは作らない それには理由があるんですよ
行った善行為を思い出したら
新たな善行になる だから忘れないようにメモっておくんです
今日と 行きました 仏堂のところは掃除しましたとかね
今日は満月で八回を守りましたとか
この伝統的な仏教徒のこの落とし穴なんです
あの人々は功徳に執着しているんです
善行為に執着しているんです
執着が心を汚すんです
だから 結果として解脱に達することはできなくなるんです
だからテーラワーダ世界では
もう解脱に達する人はものすごくものの見事に少ないんです
はめられているんです
善行為の説法で だから皆様に皆様方ついてます
全部教えたんです 問題なく
善行為しなきゃダメなんです
幸福にならない 貪瞋痴をなくさなくちゃいけない
だからやり方は期待せず
期待というのは幸福の期待なんです
善行為をする それで自分が結果として貪瞋痴を戒める
弱めることを理想 例えばお布施をしていいお布施をしました
この金額やではなくて
どれぐらい自分の欲と戦ったのかと
そちらにポイントを入れてみてください
あなたは 10万でしょ
私は 500 万も寄付しましたからね
どう？って これで心汚れてるんです
だから 10 万か 500 万じゃないんです
どれぐらい欲と戦ったのかと
例えば すごく収入に恵まれている人は
また恵まれた人 単語を善行為で覚醒のね
すごい収入がある その人にとってはあまり無理をしなくてもお金が入る
その人には 500 万というのは何のこともない
しかし やっと仕事をして
家賃も払って なんとかそれなりに食べて
ほんのちょっと 1 万 2万とかね
貯金してして 10万になったら 10 万を寄付すると
その人はものすごい自分の欲と戦ってますよ
だから 功徳の力がどれぐらい貪瞋痴に戦ったのかということで計算するものなんです
だからこれは内面的なもので
客観的に言うことはできません
内面の問題です それは勉強してください
皆様方は死後天国に生まれるための目的で善行為をやめてください
そんなのは当然生まれるんです
別に 死後天国に行く前に今世で幸福になります
そんなことはどうでもいいんです
どれぐらい心清らかにしたのかと
それだけチェックしてください
それで人は幸福は必然になる生き方を歩むことになります
で はい 善行為 功徳行為を正しく理解しましょう
はい 次に行きます あ これあった
次 善行為を稼ぐ人々 まあ説明しましたから飛ばしましょう
どれぐらい善行為をしたのかと数えてみる仏教徒がいるのです
それで究極の幸福に達しません
だって執着あるんだから
善行為をする自分の心はどれぐらい貪瞋痴を制御しているのかとチェックするべきです
正発正道に入ります その人は正なる発正道にオートで入っちゃうんです
解脱に達します だから仏道の場合は
例えば善行為をする人は健康になる
心の汚れがない人は仕事をすると成功する
心の汚れがなく 商売する人にはお客さんがもう無理やり飛んでくる
問題ないんです コマーシャル出す必要ないんです
あのお店はいいですよと
みんな知らない この心の働きで客を引っ張られているんだと
自分が客を引っ張ることはしないんです
客が引かれるだけ 勝手に
だから善行為始めたら
もう何でも健康にもなるし
体美しくなるし 食べ過ぎにならないし
だから太る太り気味にはならないし
全然落ち込まないし 精神的な病気にもならないし
いつでもニコニコ明るい顔でいられるし
人と比べませんだから誰だって仲良くすることはできるし
きりがなく幸福になる
はい それで話は終了です
ありがとうございます
長老ありがとうございました
正観ってパーリ語でいうとアビダンマのことですか？ はいはい
それとすいません もう一つなんですけど
善行為をする前としている間とした後に自分の心をチェックしてやるようにしているんですけど
その前のスライドであまり苦労に執着するとよくないという話があったと思うんですが
なんかそこら辺のバランスが難しいなと思ってですね
涅槃覚悟になって善行為をするっていうのは
いいダーマチャンダになるのか
それとか執着になっちゃうんでしょうか
あの善行為に執着するんじゃなくて
善行為を喜ぶんですよ
それは幸福なんいいことできました
よかったと 喜びと執着は違うんです
仏教は喜びを推進する
喜びの反対はね もう何て言ったっけ？悲しみでしょ
悲しみは悪でしょ 怒りの結果
だから善行為すると わずかな善行為でもね
喜びが生まれるんです
例えばゴートミ僧侶で掃除機をかける
あ 終わった よかった きれいになっちゃった
それで喜びを感じてください
喜びを感じると まあそこでその場で結果が得たことになります
そこで欲を抑えたか 例えばあの勉強会終わったら
時間がある方々は後片付け手伝ってくださいという
そこで自分には本当に時間がないんです
何か買い物しなくちゃいけないとかね
でもそこでいい これよりは善行為すると
そこで自分の欲をいくらか抑えたんですね
時間あり余っている人より
時間がなくてすごい超忙しい人がそれやったら
そこで欲を抑えているでしょ
そこで大体個々の条件によりますからね
時間が余ったらお寺の掃除してあげますと言うと
あんまり欲の戒めがなくなるんですね
時間あるかないかではなく
もう福祉活動だからやりますと
例えば地震で人々が困っている時は同時に雨も降っている
雨が降ってないんだったらボランティアできるのにと
雨が上がって晴れたら行ってボランティアする
雨が降ると帰るっていうのよりは
雨が降ろうが寝るところあろうがなかろうが関係なくボランティアする人がかなり自己愛を捨てているんですね
そういう風にチェックしてみてください
それで 答えた あまり聞こえなかったんだけど
質問は  なんとなくよくわかりました
とりあえず あの スッカと来るとか
そういうものを今感じるようにすればいいのかなって理解しました
はい 頑張ってください
はい 他の方どなたか  あの
今日初めて参加させていただきました
で あの長老の本を何冊も読ませていただいて
で 私自身がこれまでいろんな教えというか
その脳科学とか心理学とか哲学とか
当然仏教もなんですが
いろいろ学んできて 何かこうツッキしなかったんですが
長老の本を読んで 長老の教えが私にぴったり合ってるなと思ったんですけれども
今日のお話の中で 自分の気持ちに合った教えにすがると不幸になるというようなことがあって
さっきもテーラワーダ仏教協会に入会したところなんですけれども
それで良かったかどうか聞きたいんですけれども
やられましたね あの人はそれぞれなんですよ
人は真理を探し求める人もいるんです
納得いくものを探し求める人もいるんですね
ですから これ貪瞋痴はあるかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりどこかで本当のことを知りたい
真理を知りたい 納得いくものに行きたいという人々も結構いるんです
だから それで気持ちよくぴったし合う可能性はありますよ
で それ問題ないんです
それはもうあなたの業なんです
あなたの業で くだらんことばっかしにもうやられるなよとあなたの業が言ってるんです
もっと調べなさいよ だからあなたの素直な気持ちでしょ
調べたいと それは貪瞋痴じゃないんです
そういうことで あの一般論で自分の気持ちに合うものっていうのは
もう世間のその他大勢なんですね
あなた方みたいな人間っていうのは少数派なんです
だからそこはそんなに問題ないと思います
はい  安心しました ありがとうございます
はい 他の方にはどうか
はい じゃあちょっと奥の方の方から
あの業についてなんですが
業っていうのはいまいち意味がわからなくて
その行為とかそういう意味合いではないんですかね
ちょっと聞き取れなかった
ちょっとよくわからなくて
業について教えていただきたい
ちょっと対するさんに
はい 業について教えていただきたいということで
業というと言われると
なんかいまいちピンとこないということで
行為という風に考えてるといいのでしょうかという
えーと あの業っていうのは難しいんですよ
まず あの 私たちはなんかみんな生かされている
生かされていると言ってるでしょ
ということは 自分で管理できない何か働きがあるんですね
だから性格ということもあるでしょ
性格はもう嫌だなと思っても直らない
そういう風に このそれが業の管轄で業が決まっているんですね
その場合 業っていうのは今心にある衝動
そこで新たな業を作るためには行為しなくちゃいけない
行為が業ではないのです
パーリ語で同じ単語だから使ってます
日本語になるとそういう風に同じ同義語で取る必要はないんです
お釈迦様は行為 業 両方同義語で使っているんです
それはパーリ語だからなんです
行為にもカンマという
業にもカンマという で
行為する意思があるんですね
喋りたい 歩きたいという
あの心に起きた喋りたいという意思で喋る
それでエネルギーが溜まる
喋った結果が心に溜まる
それは業なんです 新たな業なんですね
そこで この気持ちが貪瞋痴だったら悪業になる
気持ちはまあそんなに貪瞋痴でない場合は
まあ善行為になる それで普段人は善行為はしないんですね
ということは もう自然なんです
体に愛着があるし 楽しみに愛着があるし
いろんな愛着がいっぱいあるんだから
愛着で で まあ気持ちよくなるんだから
じゃあ散歩にしようと
健康にいいんだから散歩にしようという風に行為するんですね
その場合は貪瞋痴が働いている
だから善行為はお釈迦様があえてリストを作ってあげなくちゃいけなくなっちゃった
だから窃盗をするなよ
生命を慈しみなさい 人を助けなさい
施しをしなさいとかね
嫉妬するなよと 怒ら...自分に対して自分怒られた人のことも心配してあげてくださいと
そういうふうにわざわざリスト作っているんです
そのリストは不貪不瞋不痴でなければできません
例えば 怒鳴られたら怒鳴り返せというと
怒り 貪瞋痴ですね 怒鳴られてもあなたは愛語を使ってください
そういうふうにお釈迦様がリストを作っているんです
そのリストを実行すると
すべて善行になります
今の時間ではその程度でしか説明できません
だから 行為イコール業というよりは
行為を引き起こす心の衝動が業なんです
これ お釈迦様の言葉で言えば
チェータナハン ビッカヴェ カンマンワダ
だからお釈迦様はこの言葉二つだと知っていたんです
だからチェータナが意識が意識じゃない
意志が ウォリション 意志が業であると
はっきりと定義してあります
はい 以上です  はい 次の方
スライドの幸福の件なんですが
幸福を目指すと無限の幸福に達するブレーキをかけるというところの文章なんですが
よくわからなかったので
はい  例えば ある若い人がギタリストになってやるぞと決める
もしかすると その子の業が数学者になる
医者になる可能性もありますね
政治家になる可能性もありますね
自分のことわからないでしょ
目の前の感情でギタリスト
ギタリストになったらかっこいいやと
その人とギタリストになる
他全部なくなっちゃった
ブレーキかけちゃったんです
普通 学問世界そういうことでしょう
一つの専門を決めたことが他時間的に間に合わないんですね
カットするわけになります
うーん あとは自営業をやりたいと決める
自営業できれば幸せよと
その人にものすごい良い会社で仕事してくださいとオファーがあるんですよ
それは捨てる もしかすると
その仕事に就いたら ものすごい幸せになって幸福になる可能性もあります
だから そうやって自分がその時の感情で決めた幸福概念でどこまでできるのかという能力を伸ばすことはできなくなるんです
だから私はリミットをつけてはいけませんと言っているんです
ある若い子に言ったんですよ
勉強している時は 私はあまりにも成績も良くないし
だからどこかの適当な大学に
入ればいいやと 私はもう大反対で
あのね 一番一流に挑戦してください
大学の場合は  何それできませんよ
だから頑張ってみなさいと
一流の大学に行ったってだけいくしか受験するんだから
そうすると一流は落第するかもしれませんよ
東大は いいんです 自分の能力のギリギリのところの大学に入るんですね
最初からどこかの地方大学で試験に自分の番号だけ書けば合格
大学に入ったらどう？私はそういう風にからかったんですね
あなた選んだ大学はね
あの試験に答えなくていいよ
しっかりとあなたの番号を書いてください
それで大丈夫で合格 だから
なんで私はその若い子をけなったかというと
この幸福にリミットをつけているんですね
だから伸ばせるならば
伸ばせるギリギリまで伸ばしてほしい
幸福になりたければギリギリまでなってほしい
だから自分の向きで決めるなよという話です
それでよろしいですか？まだ納得いかない
では それをどうすれば
いい リミット作れない
だから私は言ったでしょ
心清らかにすることにやってください
それだけ 心清らかにすると
いろんな道が出てきて
出てきて 勝手に現れて
自らも成長していくんです
俗世間的にはまあ 1 1本の道しかない
ギタリストになるか 数学者になるか
医者になるかと 弁護士になるかと
ほんのわずかな道ですよ
しかし 心清らかにすると
ギタリストであっても抜群な人間なんです
みんなに愛されるすごい人になる
医者になっても名医になって
もう外国でも名前を知られている
多くの人を助ける人間になる
リミットがなくなる そうやって拡大するんです
ポイントは 医者になるか弁護士になるかではなくて
心清らかにしなさいな
貪瞋痴を抑えなさいというポイントなんです
はい  はい 他にも手を挙げる方がいらっしゃったかと思いますが
はい  今日はありがとうございます
無我についてお聞きしたいんですが
私はまだ無我ということをを 100 パーセント理解できている気がしなくて
例えば心を清らかにするといった時に
清らかにしようとしている自分というか
その理性っていうのは
それは私 私じゃないかと思って
私っていうのが存在しているような気がしてしまうんですけども
その辺について教えて教えていただけますでしょうか
はい 普通私がいるという感じがみんなにあるんですね
だから それをなくさなくちゃいけないというプログラムになりますね
宿題になります そこで
ご飯食べたいなと思ったら
これで私がやるんですね
うーん ちょっとテレビ見ようかなと
それでまた私がやるんでしょ？でも違う私でしょ？一時的に成り立っただけで
私が変わっちゃうんです
だから その都度その都度私という気持ちが生まれるんだけど
この私っていうのはものすごい勢いで変化していくんです
テレビ見たい私とご飯食べたい私は別々です
そこで嫌になっちゃった
寝てやるそうと思った私はまた別な私なんです
同じ正真正銘の同じ私じゃないんです
そうやって瞬間変わる私を発見してみてください
それで私っていうのは一時的な現象であるということは見えるんです
はい  ありがとうございます
自我の錯覚について教えてほしいんですけれども
えっと 自我が錯覚だっていう風に書いてあって
私は怒っている時とかに
何が起こっているん？何が私を怒らせているのかなと思った時に
あ これは自我なんだって思って
あ じゃあ自我の言うことだったら
もう聞くのはやめましょうという風に解決してたんですけれども
その自我が錯覚であるっていう
先生のどこかの文章を読んで
錯覚に怒らされてたのかと思って愕然としたことがあったんですね
でもその後 えっとなんかここ会社でひどいメールをもらって
1週間ぐらい心が傷ついていたんですね
で ずっと傷ついて いろんな心の汚れを落とそうとか
慈悲の瞑想をしようとか思っても
やっぱりそのずっと心が傷ついている状態が続いて
でもその 1週間ぐらい経った後
突然 ...自我って錯覚なんだけど
錯覚がどうして傷ついたんだろうって思ったら
もう全然その傷ついた
傷ついたのももしかして錯覚なのかなって思って
心がすごい軽くなっちゃったんです
でも そのメールを見た1週間ぐらいの間
自分が傷ついて苦しかったっていうのが事実なんです
で 自我は錯覚なのに なぜ傷ついたり苦しかったりするんでしょうか
この錯覚っていうのは
本人がわからないっていう意味でしょ
本人にとっては この悟った人から錯覚と言えます
だから私はブッダの教えをそのまま受け売りでやってるんだから
で 錯覚に生き苦しい人は知らないんですね
例えば精神病の人々を見てください
いろんな人いるでしょ
神と対話するバカがいるし
悪魔の誘惑 悪魔に誘惑されてるバカがいるし
戦争と対話して戦争の連中と対話するバカがいるしね
で 本人にお前アホでしょ？にたっても何を言うのかと
私は実際に聞こえてるからと言うんですね
だから本人が気づかないんですね
私は自分の頃に 昔ね ある若い
その当時で若い人でしたね
今亡くなったんだけどね
精神的な問題あるんですね
それですごくいい人でしたし
頼んだ仕事は大変真面目にやってくれるし
で だからまあお互いで生きたら結構仲良くみんなと生活をしたりするし
である日 こいつはどこかにね
雇われて仕事をしていて
仕事をしている仲間をぶん殴っちゃったんです
ぶん殴っちゃって仕事をクビになっちゃったんです
それで本人にとってはすごい
みんなあいつはね 人を殴っちゃうんだから
よく気をつけましょうとかね
で 私はその人のことを知っているんだから
私と随分仲良く喋るんですね
で それで 私はなんのことなく
あんた仕事をトラブっちゃったねとかね
ああ そうねと 素直に言う
それでなんでそこで人を殴ったの？って
それはですね お坊さん
私の目の前ですごい恐ろしい鬼が現れたんだと
その鬼が来て人に迷惑かけちゃうと
これ大変だから 私はぶん殴ってやると言う
本人が実際鬼を殴ったんです
で 私たちから見れば かわいそうに人が殴られてるんです
で 私はああそう で それで終わっちゃったんです
そこでわかった そうではなくて
これ実例だからね だから幻覚ある人にとっては幻覚は事実なんです
だから我々には自我という錯覚がある
だから自我いると思っているんです
しかし あなたも実践したでしょ
これは錯覚だからと思ったら怒りが消えちゃうや
悩みが消えちゃうわ だから錯覚があると苦しみが生まれるんですね
だから あの 一時的にでも
これは自我があったんだから
そんな気持ちになりましたと思って
その時の悩み苦しみをなくした方がいいんですね
正しい観察して 自我の錯覚を生める仕組みと発見してください
こういう風に自我の錯覚が生まれるんだと
仕組みを発見したら問題は解決します
はい 以上です  はい 前の方で先に
欲についてお尋ねします
私には半年以上大病を患っている兄がおります
毎日自分の瞑想が終わった後にエコーをする際に
一番最後のところで その兄の健康が回復しますように
心が平安でありますようにという風に言っていますが
よくよく自分の心を見てみると
その中に自分の気持ちの不安だったり
自分が平安でいたいという心配があって
平安でいたいという気持ちも感じる日もあります
これは欲を増やしていることになるのでしょうか？ 欲を増やさないように慈悲の瞑想してください
その方も苦しんでいるでしょう
自分も結果としてね 一緒に苦しんでいるでしょう
だから心の安穏がありますようにとかね
その方は自分の方でそういう結果受けているし
あなたもあなたの方で苦しんでいるし
だから全ての生命が平安で安穏でいますようにと
そういうふうに思った方が欲でなくなっちゃうんですね
純粋に心配するだけ 逃げたわけじゃない
業っていうのはそう簡単には変わらないし
しかし 悪い業で悩んでいる人々の心が軽らかになっていくならば
業の悪性が 弱くなって弱くなってはいくのです
だからそこら辺理解してください
ありがとうございました
では あちらの方でやりますか
あの ちょっとマイクを離して喋ってください
はい  先ほどのこちらの男性の方の質問に少し似ているんですが
今日長老がおっしゃった体は自分のものでない
心も自分のものでないと言った場合の
その自分というのは 心からも離れた自分を指しているんでしょうか
心を綺麗にする時の心にしようと心を綺麗にしようとしているものは
自分の心ですか？それとも自分ですか
うーん 難しいんだけど
どうやって説明すればいいんですかね
で その場合はこの一般論で理解しましょう
例えば自分がいると仮に仮定する
仮定して じゃあ体がその自分のものじゃないと
じゃあ心はその仮に設定した自分のものじゃないとというふうに理解するしかないんですね
そこで自分のものっていうのは
本当は自分ではなくて希望なんですよ
だから体調が良くなりたいと思う
それは希望でしょ 良くなりだと思ったんだけど
一向に体調が良くならない
それで希望通りにいかなかっただけの話なんだ
因果法則で そこで一般論で体は自分のものじゃないっていう風に言っちゃうんですね
それは瞑想する時でも
これは私のものではない
これは私のものではないと捨てて捨てていくんですね
結局全部捨てちゃうんです
そんな程度なんです 難しい
おそらく瞑想して一つ一つ長老の言う通り捨てていけば
最後はその自分もないというところがわかるのかなという解釈です
そうです じゃあボールペンの例えで言ってみましょう
ボールペンがある そこでキャップを取って
これがボールペンじゃない
捨てる そこで中の芯を取って
あの上書くところあるんで
そこはこれはボールペンじゃない
それ捨てる それでインクが入ってるもの
これは缶であって これはボールペンじゃない
捨てる それで手に取ってるボディがありますね
これはボディでボールペンじゃないと言ってる
じゃあボールペンはどこ？そんな感じなんです
組み立てたらこれがボールペンだという分解してボールペンでないものを捨てていっちゃうと線もなくなっちゃうんです
それは瞑想でやっちゃうんです
はい 頑張ってください
はい そろそろ時間になってまいりましたが
他の方いかがでしょうか
あ えっと 先ほどのお話で
誓願をすると心に進む力が入りますというお話だったんですけれども
誓願というのは何かこう強く願う
そういうことだと思っていていいのでしょうか
ん？誓願というのは何かこう特別なことがあるんですか？ あれは心理学的な現象なんですね
誓願が良いことにも悪いことにも使える
だから誓願で力入ります
なんか昔テレビで気合いだ気合いだっていう人がいたでしょ
あの娘さんをね オリンピックに出して
レスラーでしたっけね
気合いだ気合いだとかね
あれも一つの誓願ですよ
いわゆる心に力を上げて
だからお父さんが娘にものすごくはちゃめちゃなことをして
娘さんが恥ずかしくてしょうがないんだけど
お父さんのことはすごい可愛いし
大事にしているし やっぱり頑張っちゃうんですね
だからお父さんついてるんだからもう大丈夫ってことでもうはちゃめちゃ頑張ってメダルまで取っちゃう
だからお父さんのみんなお父さん恥知らずも気合いだ気合いだと言ったことは素晴らしい親の愛情なんですよ
だからそれで誓願の働きが入ったんですからね
だからそれは良いことにも悪いことにも使えますよ
だから心にちょっとエネルギーを入れてあげることなんです
だから仏教はすごく清らかな方に誓願を使ってくださいと言っているんです
はい  はい よろしいでしょうか
もし他になければ そろそろ時間なので終了したいと思います
はいはい じゃあもう一方はい
このままどうぞ  さっきのスライドでちょっとわからないところがあったので教えてほしいんですけれども
生命は貪瞋痴の感情で生きているっていうようなところなんですけども
えっと 貪瞋痴の感情でっていうのがよくわからなくて
なぜ貪瞋痴の感情で生きているのか
ちょっとわからないので
今でも教えてください
生きるということは瞬間的な幻想ですよ
命っていうのは瞬間的な現象なんですね
なんでこの現象が組み立てるの？貪瞋痴が作るんです
貪瞋痴がない人はもう生命でなくなっちゃうんです
だからみんな転生すると仏教で言ってるでしょ
インドは流れるんですね
終わりなく これ貪瞋痴の
命を作っちゃうんですね
貪瞋痴がなければ命を作れないんです
はい そういうことでしたね
うん  はい それではこれで終了したいと思います
はい これ唱えて終了します
ドゥッカパッターチェニンドゥッカ
バヤンパッターチェニンバヤー
ソーカッパッターチェニッソーカー
ホントゥサンレピパニノー
もう一回 ドゥッカッパッターチェニンドゥッカ
バヤンパッターチェニンバヤー
ソーカッパッターチェニッソーカー
ホントゥサンレピパニノー
もう一個 苦しんでない生命が苦しみなく
恐れてない生命が恐れなく
悲しんでない生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
カンティーパラマンタポーティティンカー
ニッバーナンパラマンワダンティーブッダ